[Musik]
mein vater hat irgendwie herausgefunden
dass ich nicht meinem sprachkurs bin
er ist total sauer was aber wie ich
denke nicht dass er irgendetwas abend wo
wir es haben wir denn hin
ich sollte ich von herrn altacher größen
vater ich habe gerade mit ihm
telefoniert du hast was ich habe mit
samuels vater telefoniert und ihm gesagt
dass wir hier sind ja weiß nicht was du
gemacht hast du bist du spinnst du es
war alles in ordnung dann kommst du
selber kriegt riesenärger und du bist
schuld ich finde ich dass ich an
irgendwas schuld haben was ist
eigentlich ein problem selber dass
eltern denken dass die beim
deutschunterricht ist sie darf sich
nicht mit mir treffen
seid ihr beiden zusammen nein wir sind
nur freunde aber das ist jetzt
vielleicht alles vorbei nico das ist mir
es tut mir leid ich wusste das nicht
hatte ich hab aus meinem leben als
[Musik]